the defense rests in the case of the
murder of mollie tibbetts but not before
the defendant takes the stand
his testimony added a bizarre twist in
the case of the murder
university of iowa student fox news
correspondent matt finn is live in
davenport iowa with the latest matt
lawrence it was quite a moment in court
today some of the jurors sat
forward in their seats when the man
accused of mollie tibbetts made the bold
move of taking the stand in his own
defense
26 year old illegal immigrant immigrant
christian rivera's
shocking testimony contradicts what he
had previously told police regarding how
20 year old molly tibbetts was brutally
stabbed to death rivera claims
on the night tibbetts went missing he
took a shower at his house
two masked men came through the front
door then extra instructed him into his
car to drive them to molly tibbetts town
where they circled her on her jog
rivera claims that on that ride one of
the masked men called the other
jack which is the last name of molly
tibbetts boyfriend
rivera says he doesn't know how the two
alleged men killed tibbetts
but afterwards he instructed them to
drive to a cornfield
and the two men left on foot rivera
claims he dumped tibbett's body
then later realized his cell phone and
keys and molly tibbetts
fitbit were in his trunk he dumped her
cell phone in fitbit on the side of the
road and
claims he kept it all a secret because
he claims those masked
men threatened to harm his daughter and
her mother his ex-girlfriend
do you remember being asked in the
interview by
ms romero if you were covering for
anyone
yes and you told her that you were not
is that correct
correct at that moment i was really
scared
i understand that you may have been
scared but you chose not to
tell them correct correct
rivera is charged with first degree
murder he has pleaded not guilty this
case
is expected to go to the jury tomorrow
so we could be on verdict to watch
at some point tomorrow lawrence thank
you matt
got to be really demented to confess to
a murder and then make up this nonsense
and for a
court of law